[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
dexter new blood episode 4 h is for hero
this was written by tony saltzman and
directed by sanford bookstaver so this
episode did so many things right and
brought my hopes back up for the season
where i was hard on the last episode
with a lot of worries of it not feeling
fresh enough and getting a little too
slow but this episode really had a theme
going on that worked so well about you
know going back to title ages for hero
here but going to that we all have two
sides to us like we hear in harrison's
monologue at the end here about we all
have a little bit of hero and a little
bit of monster and that's what the show
dexter is all about the other day with
the character of dexter and it's leaning
into that with harrison here and like i
said just when i first started watching
dexter that it reminded me so much of a
lot of even the marvel netflix shows
right like daredevil punisher and they
even bring up punisher here where you're
having these gray areas of hero where
dexter is in that category where dexter
kills but he's doing it for a just cause
he's not just killing anyone to kill he
he wants to get rid of bad people that
aren't getting their due justice from
the justice system so i really liked a
lot of things going on here with deborah
in particular i've been saying those are
some of the strongest moments with
deborah and dexter but that continues
here and i love how they open with her
playing detective and kind of putting
the pieces together this mystery of why
kurt would lie about his son being alive
and he she's got good theories but it's
interesting too because it's also coming
from dexter's head deborah so it's a
part of him obviously thinking these
things and how maybe kurt doesn't want
the cops involved or that he's just
trying to take care of everything
himself or that he's got already maybe
some theories about it being dexter
which we'll see later on the episode
that dexter kind of slips up in front of
kurt about knowing about matt actually
being the one driving this boat so i
thought that was actually good that they
were kind of planting seeds to little
you know stories here that go through
the whole story of the season we're
getting little things touched on like in
particular with kurt and how dex sees
kurt with this girl at the diner which
already to us seems odd and is going to
lead into theories about him being this
other killer we see but i also thought
they did a good job of kind of bleeding
that into this episode without taking
away from the spotlight of harrison's
story here and you know we see at the
end of this episode that kurt actually
does take this girl chloe from the diner
he offers her a job we know he's been
giving her money but he actually brings
her back to his place that looks exactly
like the place of this killer it still
could be a red herring that they might
be toying with us but i mean i think it
all but confirms he is that killer who's
shot the girl before and is responsible
for all these missing women in this town
they also develop well this character
now of molly park who's the podcaster
because they're bringing her in to
angela's story what angela is doing but
it gives it a more fresh take than just
having a detective go through these
cases but i did think it was interesting
like angel even alludes to like weren't
you here to cover matt caldwell's story
but molly is actually more interested
now in the missing person's case that's
on the wall and of course showtime
throws in homeland references synergy
right you got two jokes about carrie
bear which i thought was funny but you
know a little bit overkill with the
second joke you know because they want
to get homeland on the mine same network
here but i think that it's interesting
that molly's gonna be looking into that
because again that's gonna kind of
actually aim maybe molly towards finding
out about kurt and that killer more than
knowing more about dexter so she might
actually end up being dexter saving
grace in the end and having the real
villain here caught now i thought it was
so crucial and an important character
moment for harrison i thought which was
great they put in this episode to kind
of warm us up to the idea of what
actually harrison does here with lying
about what happened to ethan and we know
that he stabbed him here and dexter
figures it out but having this scene
where harrison goes through molly park's
podcast episodes and finds one is on the
trinity killer so we get a nice little
shot of john lithgow there and we get to
see rita again but it's interesting and
fascinating to see harrison's just
reaction to someone talking about it and
basically saying like how messed up the
sun must be having his mother you know
in a pool of blood in front of him dead
killed in front of him like dexter so
that gets its payoff and it gets you set
up to the idea of him being like dexter
and how that affects him and setting him
off to do what he did to ethan this
scene was right before dexter gets a
phone call about the incident at the
school so it definitely was a trigger
for harrison and i have to give props to
the actor of harrison jack alcott here
i've already given some props but it's
such a vital character that they needed
the actor to do good here and he's been
bringing it holding his own and handling
such heavy scenes and showing a lot of
motion on his face but i thought he was
really good here when he was lying about
what happened with ethan not giving the
clear story and dexter's kind of reading
through that but i also thought he was
good here when he sees ethan's parents
and showing that guilt in his face and
where there is that difference between
him and dexter is yeah maybe they both
kill or maybe not for harrison kill but
stop in a violent way you know someone
doing something horrible but he's got
guilt there harrison you see that with
the parents and the parents are saying
they're not going to live a normal life
anymore they're getting death threats
and that ethan might fall for harrison's
crime and i don't know how much
harrison's gonna be able to go through
with that where dexter's a little more
in the case of he can kind of not let
guilt just overbear him like we see
harrison is dealing with that's a big
difference i'm seeing between the two
right now which i think is interesting i
love moments between harrison and dexter
here where harrison the beginning
episode says to dexter what do you do to
deal when you have something you know
violent happened in front of you and
he's like i love the narration of
dexter's like i wrap guys in plastic and
kill them just the way that michael c
hall just says lines of this so casually
is great but i love too that deb is
toying with dexter this whole episode
saying like hi you know harrison's
different than you he's not what you
want to be he's not a monster he he's
emotional he's empathetic a hero you
know and she's saying not like you but
you know at the end of the day dexter's
instinct about harrison is right and
that yeah he has a lot of dexter in him
so that is just a great back and forth
between him and deborah and still having
humorous moments where deborah's like
showing that he wanted to be a hero and
has all the science room i thought that
was great too and that was a great scene
in general just having dexter do what we
love to see him do kind of do his blood
work and his investigation at the scene
himself but working out his head with
deborah and them debating it i thought
was a great great scene one of the
standouts for the season for sure and
yeah it's a big mess up on harrison's
part if you go back and look that when
he had known about these drawings from
ethan that he like kind of smirked at
them last episode and didn't do anything
about it like yeah he should have told
somebody about those drawings because
it's clearly a threat to the school and
there was also a big line in the scene
where dexter says that to deb that
harrison almost you know seems like he
fit the code here with ethan so he's
seeing that that same kind of okay if
he's doing something violent at least
he's doing it to stop something like a
school shooting i also love you guys
theories on this quick scene that
happens where kurt actually shows up
gives a gift to harrison for being a
hero he says but it's a drone so that
has to come back for some reason they
don't just throw that scene in for no
reason and why is it a drone you know
maybe kurt is on to them and harrison
and dex and he's gonna have a feed to it
i'd love to hear you guys theory and why
there was a drone or do you think it's
just absolutely means nothing so my
favorite moment of the season so far was
harrison having this moment to stand up
and talk to everyone who's on this kill
list and they're all praising him like a
hero but they're all ragging on ethan
still and like how ethan's this psycho
and painting him in that box but
harrison sticks up for ethan and says he
was a victim too and calling them out
for their you know causing him to act
this way which i love and makes harrison
likeable but it's showing again he's
more vocal than dexter about these kind
of things and what he's doing and why
he's doing the things he does yeah he's
still lying like dexter they didn't do
anything but he's actually vocal about
his thoughts like this where dexter kind
of keeps that to himself and i think
that obviously harrison's more human
than dexter but it's also brilliant
because this scene was so good editing
wise
going through having the narration of
harrison here but showing dexter look
through harrison's stuff and also having
the reveal of curt bringing that girl to
his house it just makes an exciting
cliffhanger here to lead to the ultimate
reveal that he has a straight razor and
it's great that they had deborah show up
here emotional crying like oh my god
like yeah harrison maybe this monster
like you dexter and i love the line
trinity used straight razor to kill his
mother born in blood just like you and
it's just great dexter says he has my
dark passenger and that smirk i was just
like wow that was just crazy
exciting cliffhanger and an awesome
reveal and i like that it's tying back
to the trinity killer here and that it
makes complete sense for harrison's
character to have that as his you know
choice here weapon of choice of a
straight razor and that effect he would
have just like dexter growing up around
death with his mother so i really
thought this was a great episode i'm
gonna give it a 9.3 i think it was the
best of the season you know even just a
little better than the premiere which i
loved as well so it gave me a lot of
hope i like where things are going here
the only thing i'm a little concerned
about is i hope they don't give away too
much too fast where it can get a little
boring lose a mystery i really don't
hope it's kurt here as the killer
honestly because it's just so obvious
you know and i would like that to stay
something we're kind of guessing instead
of just be like yeah it's the guy
everyone thought it was you know so i
hope that it doesn't get predictable
like that i still think we can't call it
yet on curtin that there's plenty of
season to go and there could be red
herrings and more complications to this
story about these missing women so i
hope they keep it that way and not just
kind of reveal everything too soon but
i'm loving this relationship between
dexter and harrison i'm loving the
scenes with dexter and deborah but also
learning more about harrison there could
still be some red herrings with harrison
here too because remember there is a
line for going you know maybe an extreme
theory here that deborah says to him
like you're making this all in your head
dexter so there is a point that yeah
maybe ethan's just saying harrison
stabbed him but maybe ethan is lying and
i just cover his own butt and maybe you
know harrison was actually stabbed so
that maybe is our judgment like dexter
that we're just assuming he's like him
so that could also be something too it's
a stretch but it is interesting that
deborah said that line when he was in
the scene investigating the crime that
he's kind of making what he wants to
happen happen so that's that's something
that could be a thing but let me know
what you thought of it down below i'd
love to hear your thoughts i read every
comment i try to respond as many as i
can please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews of dexter
i'm doing every episode i also do movie
reviews and celebrity interviews as well
so you're gonna check those out and if
you really love what i do here i'd
really appreciate if you become a member
today it will help me so much i can
cover more shows and movies and do this
full time one day and you'll get special
perks and it would be just something i'm
truly grateful for and please follow me
at steveharleyshow on twitter instagram
and now tiktok for more of me and i'll
see you next time